How much of civilization is shaped by our
biology? How might our cities, transportation,
and technology look different if we weren’t a
group of nearly hairless primates? The video game
Spore has the answers. Okay, well, maybe not the
answers — but Spore does offer an interesting case
study into the fundamentals of how a speculative
lifeform might build a society. In our first Spore
episode, we followed a lifeform from a microscopic
organism to the intelligent Curiousus Sapiens.
In this episode, we’ll witness the ascent of
their civilization, and explore how the unique
biology of an alien like Curiousus Sapiens would
affect things like the design of clothing, the
schematics of vehicles, and shapes of buildings
in unexpected ways. We’ll begin with Tribal
Stage and go all the way to Space, completing the
multi-billion-year-tale of Curiousus Sapiens. So,
let’s return to Planet Curious, and
discover the finale of the story of life…
After the early evolutionary stages, the birth
of society is underway — with Curiousus Sapiens
building fires and early lodgings.
But is this the dawn of a wise people,
or a culture of warmongering tyrants? What path
will Curiosus Sapiens take in shaping the destiny
of their planet? Like the game’s biology, cultural
evolution in Spore is fairly simplified and
exaggerated. ‘Tribal Stage’ seems to be a mesh
of various eras, but seems most comparable to a
hunter-gatherer culture. At this point in history,
Curious Sapiens appear only to have access to
simple technologies quite similar to that of
early humans. It might seem surprising that
Curiosus Sapiens would converge on concepts like
pottery — but there is some precedent for this
idea. On earth, certain technologies are ‘cultural
universals’ — meaning that numerous cultures
invented a version of them independently from
one another. The sheer number of times disparate
populations have invented something like pottery
indicates that when intelligent minds are faced
with the same problem — similar answers might
emerge. Whether or not this would hold true for an
alien in an alien environment is difficult to
say — but depending on the circumstances, Curious
Sapiens inventing pottery is certainly possible.
As technology improves, Spore gives us the option
to determine the clothing of Curiousus Sapiens.
The question of what kind of clothes an emerging
sapient alien species would wear — assuming they’d
wear clothing at all — is actually a tricky one.
Clothing is so ubiquitous today for us Homo
Sapiens that we almost don’t think about it.
The initial invention of clothing was likely
tied to the climate, and served as a way to
protect our hairless bodies from the elements.
Yet compared to Earth, Planet Curious — like
most planets in Spore — seems to have an extremely
temperate macroclimate, so it’s unlikely clothing
would develop for temperature control alone. Yet
clothing can also protect the body from specific
environmental hazards like pests, abrasive
substances, and other irritants. So, it’s
possible that protective attire would first emerge
in Curiousus Sapiens in particularly vulnerable
areas — like the base of their eye-stalks. Human
clothing also has various social functions across
cultures, and some articles of alien clothing
could serve in these ways. Unlike humans,
Curiousus Sapiens have an elaborate display
structure sprouting from their shoulders, similar
to the extravagant plumages of certain birds.
It’s not too big a leap to assume garments would
be built around complementing these structures
— making them appear fuller and more impressive.
An emergent hunter-gatherer species would also
likely find value in various satchels or pouches
to carry resources. And finally, aliens might
develop some articles of clothing with no apparent
function whatsoever — either as reflections of
cultural trends or expressions of personal style.
In the case of Curiousus Sapiens, clothing
choices would be limited by available
materials — which in this age would likely
comprise hides, grass, leaves, and shells.
The end result is attire that certainly looks
pretty strange to our eyes… but a Curiousus
Sapiens would likely find the eccentricities of
our clothing just as puzzling… As time passes,
Curiousus Sapiens fall into a rhythm within the
hunter-gatherer lifestyle, with obtaining food the
most important task during this era. Historically,
permanent settlements on Earth rarely emerge
until after the invention of agriculture and
domesticated plants. Spore skips over any mention
of agriculture, but realistically we can assume
that Curiousus Sapiens have some early version
of subsistence farming figured out. And Curiousus
Sapiens aren’t the only lifeforms to have achieved
advanced intelligence. Across Planet Curious,
other species are building their own societies.
Different unrelated species all reaching the
same level of technological advancement during
the exact same period isn’t particularly likely…
but this is how Spore functions. The question is,
how will Curiousus Sapiens choose to interact
with their new neighbors going forwards?
To guide Curiousus Sapiens through this
new era, two tools are now available for
construction — the spear and the wooden horn,
which looks like a kind of rudimentary flute.
As far as early tools go, these are actually
fairly plausible. Spears are the oldest weapon
we have an unambiguous archeological record of,
dating back to the Paleolithic age. Likewise,
mammoth bone flutes from the Paleolithic are the
oldest known musical instruments. Realistically,
however, the tools of a species like Curiousus
Sapiens would likely be different from our own.
For one, since Curiousus Sapiens only have four
fingers instead of five, their musical instruments
would likely look different, as they’d likely
only have access to a pentatonic scale instead of
a heptatonic one when playing a wind instrument
— with five notes per octave instead of seven.
Likewise, it’s interesting to deliberate on
whether a lifeform like Curiousus Sapiens
would develop a spear in the first place. Humans
lack the claws and fangs of most top predators
in the animal kingdom, pressuring early humans to
invent tools to compete with the natural weaponry
of other animals. Yet an unarmed Curiousus
Sapiens is already a formidable customer,
and might not need to be as creative. Still, it’s
possible that any emergent tool user would be able
to puzzle out the basic concept that sticking
something sharp on the end of something long is
a good way to deal damage while keeping yourself
out of harm’s reach. In either case, with their
new tools, Curiousus Sapiens can now enchant
other species with their musical instruments…
or impale them on the end of their spear. As
thinking social omnivores, Curiousus Sapiens make
allies when they can. But when another species
attacks first, Curiousus Sapiens respond in kind.
In a trend that sadly echoes our own history,
this early era is marked by frequent conflict...
But society is also changing in other ways.
Curiousus Sapiens are on the path towards
creating a larger and more stable civilization —
a path laden with new developments. At this point,
Curiousus Sapiens gain the ability to domesticate
animals — a crucial trait for emergent
civilizations. There’s a lot that could be said
about animal domestication, but to simplify:
we humans began our animal domestication journey
with wolves before the agricultural revolution,
then moved on to small herbivores like sheep
and goats once we began staying in one place for
longer. Beasts of burden that could plow fields or
give you a ride like cows and horses came later.
Curiousus Sapiens will begin their journey
with this small bird-like quadruped, harvesting
their feathers for clothing and construction
materials and their eggs for dietary consumption.
Generations later, the second animal Curiousus
Sapiens domesticate is this large… horrifying
spider-beast. These hardy giants might look
intimidating, but they’re actually quite docile,
and will fill the role of plow animals.
It’s worth noting that while, once again,
Spore never touches on agriculture, in order
for this sort of domestication to be possible,
Curiousus Sapiens must have begun the practice.
And with these animals in their corner,
the population can grow to new sizes, and
society itself can become more complex.
New buildings are now available, like this
outlet for fishing spears — seemingly implying
the emergence of small industries and the
increased specialization of tasks within
Curious Sapiens society. And just looking at their
society, culture seems richer and more diverse,
with different Curious Sapiens sharing
ideas and playing musical instruments.
After making one final alliance, Spore gives
us the option to advance to the next stage…
Hurtling forwards in time, ‘Civilization Stage’
begins with the option to build a modern building.
Once again, Spore’s timeline of historical change
is certainly a simplified one, as there are,
historically, numerous steps between small
subsistence societies and an emergent industrial
civilization. Likewise, Spore puts no limits
on this first building, letting you construct
something truly absurd if you feel like it. Fun
as that can be, it’s interesting to consider what
an early industrial house might look like for a
Curiousus Sapiens. Unlike humans Curiousus Sapiens
are nest builders — and have been for the past
several hundred million years of their evolution.
As a result, it’s possible that their instinct
for houses would be different from our
own — building smaller, more low-to-the-grown
dwellings that evoke their ancestral nests.
With a town hall constructed, the Curiousus
Sapiens debate the nature of their society.
With a stable food supply, natural resources
like Spice — which flows from most planets
in Spore — becomes the new valued commodity. The
value of Spice in Spore reminds me of the sci-fi
world of Dune, and if my memory of that series
is accurate, a reliance on Spice might cause…
problems. But for now, Curiousus Sapiens are a
young populace with their heads lost in the dream
of the future... On that note, Spore gives us the
option to design our first vehicle that will help
with transporting the spice. As always, Spore
lets you design whatever absurd thing you want,
but alien cars genuinely might not look like
we’d expect. Certain things like wheels could be
universal considering the constraints of physics.
Yet our vehicles reflect us more than we realize.
Several studies have shown that when we look at
most cars, our brains’ facial recognition cortex
is activated. This isn’t a coincidence — cars are
designed to subtly resemble human faces to appeal
to our pattern-seeking minds. And if Curiousus
Sapiens have similar instincts, it's likely their
vehicles would subtly reflect the geometry of
their faces… With our first vehicle constructed,
the Spice can be gathered and transported — for
better or worse. In this era, other civilizations
of Curiousus Sapiens have also emerged. We’ve
already seen this species, much like humans,
has the potential for war and cooperation — so
the ultimate future of Planet Curious will be
determined by how well they can work together.
Contacting our closest neighbors, we can offer
gifts, compliment them, or say their people
are ‘descended from limbless space slugs.’ Now,
I’m no political expert, but I suspect one of the
first two options is a better tactic... Thanks to
such savvy political acumen, the two civilizations
establish a trade route and begin the long road
towards a united future… As time passes, cities
become larger and full of new technologies. Thanks
to the steady force of negotiation, alliances form
— first with immediate neighbors, and then with
more distant countries. As technology improves,
clothing evolves as well, featuring new textiles
and construction materials. I tried to make the
post-industrial clothes of Curiousus Sapiens
still vaguely echo earlier culture trends. Got
to keep those silly hats, after all. In time, we
unlock the secrets of motorized flying machines,
and can design our first air vehicles. Here,
the constraints of things like wind resistance
might shape our craft into something similar to
the planes we have on Earth, although just like
with their land vehicles, Curiousus Sapiens may
build something that subtly reflects the geometry
of their faces. And with their natural stalk
eyes and more flexible necks Curiousus Sapiens
likely have a greater visual field than humans,
so the cockpits of their aircrafts might
have more windows to the sides and back.
With aircrafts now soaring through the atmosphere,
the planet is more connected through trade than
ever before. Achieving planetary peace through
careful management and negation is admittedly
not the most exciting way to play, but it’s
certainly worth it. At the end of this era,
Curiousus Sapiens are united under one banner, and
looking towards the stars as their next horizon...
And so, the final chapter, ‘Space Stage’, begins.
Curiousus Sapiens are no longer beholden to just
a single, meager world. After designing a
spacecraft that follows the same aesthetic
standards of the other vehicles, for the first
time, Curiousus Sapiens are free to explore beyond
the protective atmosphere of their home. Traveling
to another planet in the system, the Sapiens
discover a crashed vessel, and are lucky enough
to scan and replicate its interstellar drive.
From the perspective of the player, you
can zoom out and behold the entire galaxy,
spinning just like how it is in the title screen —
except now you can go to any part of it you like.
That first moment when you realize the whole
galaxy is now yours to explore is pretty magical,
and makes the scope of Spore feel so impossibly
vast. The galaxy is waiting, and the rest is up
to you. Every one of these stars contains
their own system of orbiting planets,
which you can fly down to and visit. At the
time when Spore first came out, this kind
of procedurally generated universe was something
never really attempted before. At the same time,
such scale has its drawbacks. It’s hard not to
feel like, in a galaxy this large, nothing you do
has much meaning. I know a lot of people’s least
favorite stage is Space Stage, and I understand
why. It’s easy to become disconnected from the
creature you started with billions of years ago,
although perhaps that’s an unavoidable symptom of
a species becoming a galaxy-spanning civilization.
Expanding across the cosmos, Curiousus Sapiens
gain the ability to build self-assembling colonies
on barren worlds. In their expansion, they search
for radio wave frequencies that might signal the
presence of technologically-advanced life like
themselves. On our planet, we’re scanning the
stars for alien life by searching for similar
frequencies — although with our limited range,
so far, we’ve found nothing but silence. Yet
Curiousus Sapiens can journey much further out
across the stars, and eventually they encounter
other intelligent, space-faring life who rose from
the primordial soup just like they did. In time,
Curiousus Sapiens even unlock the secrets of life,
and can create creatures to populate newly
terraformed worlds. This kind of power can
be used to create bizarre forms of life,
as biology becomes an infinite playground.
In the words of science fiction author Arthur
C. Clarke, “any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic,” and that
adage holds true here. It can also be used
more responsibly, and we’d have to hope such
an advanced form of life would be sensible with
their power. Looking forwards, Curious Sapiens
will ascend to a civilization we can’t fathom,
transcending technology beyond
the scope of our limited minds…
By design, Spore skips over many of the stages
of history, condensing and exaggerating the
long road of technological advancement. Yet
the game does explore a surprising number of
the universal principles of how civilizations and
technology change over time. I know not everybody
likes the later stages of Spore compared to Cell
and Creature, and I can understand that. Still,
the novelty of guiding a speculative creature
through their technological advancement is pretty
intriguing even all these years later. Like I said
in part one, I’d love to see another high-profile
game tackle something similar, as I feel there’s
real potential for a modern take on this concept.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry,
please lend your support to help make these
videos possible by liking, subscribing, and
hitting the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things Curious. See you in the next video.